on
le wine massy saclay tu sais c'est un
peu son objectif c'est vraiment de
connecter à la fois les chercheurs les
étudiants et des entreprises de
l'écosystème du plateau de saclay et de
le faire dans une dimension où on est
intégré au programme innovant connect
innoven connect c'est quoi son adn c'est
de connecter les clients entreprises de
bnp paribas avec les startups qu'on aime
et berges donc les start up
elles ont besoin client et nos clients
entreprises de bnp paribas elles ont
besoin d'innovation dont sont porteuses
les start up
nous avons choisi le thème de l'humain
augmenté vers le transhumanisme parce
que ils l'intègrent à la fois à la
problématique de la robotique de
l'intelligence artificielle et des
implants et on pense que ces trois
thèmes sont au coeur d'une révolution à
la fois industriel et d' usage
deux forums il s'adresse à la fois aux
chercheurs à la fois aux étudiants et à
la fois aux entreprises c'est à dire que
ce qu'on essaye de faire
c'est vraiment un lien entre ces trois
univers de faire un pont au maximum pour
qu'il apporte à chaque fois leur
excellence ils ont tous à apprendre à
partager des choses ensemble donc
typiquement cet après-midi refaire des
ateliers collaboratif où on va avoir des
chercheurs des étudiants et des
entrepreneurs qui vont essayer grâce à
l'intelligence collective de faire
émerger des choses s'est ouvert aux
start up bien évidemment aux entreprises
tpe pme au grand compte vous avez ici
des directeurs de l'innovation de grands
groupes
vous avez des pme vous avez des
étudiants vous avez des chercheurs qui
sont là donc l'idée c'est vraiment tous
ceux qui sont intéressés par ce sujet et
d'avoir une ouverture la plus large
possible
sur plateau saclay vous avez un
écosystème qui est propice vous avez
safran vous avez à thales vous avez
airbus
vous avez les grands groupes qui sont au
coeur de ces sujets et à côté de ça vous
avez des étudiants des chercheurs qui
aussi sont intéressés et complètement
passionnée par ce sujet